[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the many reasons why
Albus Percival will Frick Brian
Dumbledore famed Headmaster of Hogwarts
and former Gryffindor student may have
been more well suited to Southern house
as fans soon after Harry Potter received
his letter of acceptance and we were
first introduced to Hogwarts schools
which Carlton was a dream we also
learned about the magical institutions
for founding members and how they
decided that the student population
would always be divided into four houses
which would represent the
characteristics and traits most valued
by each of those four founding members
as the majority of you watching this
will already know the four founding
members of Hogwarts School were godric
Gryffindor Helga Hufflepuff Rowena
Ravenclaw and Salazar sutherin with the
corresponding houses being named after
each of their surnames and while later
installment of the series eventually
focused on students from the houses of
Hufflepuff and Ravenclaw the beginning
of Harry Potter certainly had a lot more
emphasis on Gryffindor and Southern
what's more there was a very obvious
dichosomy presented between the two with
all of the protagonist characters aka
the good guys being gryffindors and all
of the antagonists or bad guys being so
veterans from Harry to the compassionate
and friendly Weasley family who helped
him find platform nine and three
quarters and the world famous Headmaster
Albus Dumbledore everyone who was
presented as good and heroic in the
first few years of Harry's time at
Hogwarts was a current or former
Gryffindor student by contrast each of
the baddies that we met during Harry's
first few years were all slytherins
including the bully Drake or Malfoy the
cruel Professor Snape and of course the
most evil wizard to have ever lived Lord
Voldemort and who could forget what
Hagrid told Harry before he entered his
first year at Hogwarts there's not a
single witch or wizard who went bad who
wasn't in Slytherin you know who was one
as the series continues on and The
Wizarding World grows however
adjustments were made that seemed to be
trying to rectify this initial black and
white world where all of the best
witches and wizards were gryffindors and
all of the most evil ones were
Sutherlands for example years after the
final book was published
wizardingworld.com revealed the great
and powerful wizard Merlin Lynn was once
a Slytherin student describing the many
Great accomplishments he achieved during
his lifetime to support all of wizard
kind despite their blood Purity or
ancestry because oh yeah almost all
slytherins were previously described as
being super prejudiced as well so it
would seem that Professor Albus
Dumbledore who's initially presented as
a mentor and hero to Harry was most
likely made to be a Gryffindor simply
because it aligned with the universe's
limited perspective of good versus evil
at the time after all the Philosopher's
Stone to novel written for a rather
young readership considering the overall
story language and age of the central
character Harry Potter but as the novels
progressed the plot lines matured and
the characters evolved so did our
perspective and understanding of many of
the witches and wizards presented
throughout the series Professor Snape as
it turned out wasn't a two-dimensional
desperately evil Death Eater and nor was
Albus Dumbledore simply a wise old was
hero who was Gryffindor through and
through in fact as mentioned earlier on
some of Dumbledore's most prominent
characteristics were actually incredibly
Southern in nature and other top traits
associated with that house ambition
resourcefulness and cunningness Albus
Dumbledore had them in Spades if not in
his later years certainly in his youth
this means that when he was sorted into
his house at Hogwarts he would have
displayed immense ambition after
Dumbledore's death in Harry's sixth year
at Hogwarts we come to learn about a
side of the Headmaster that had
previously been kept quite Secret at
least from Harry he was once terribly
ambitious in his youth after Albus
graduated from Hogwarts he planned to
travel the world believing himself to be
an incredibly brilliant and gifted young
wizard which shows he was also rather
arrogant another trait often associated
with Slytherin
tragically before setting off on his
world travels Albus lost his mother and
was left with the responsibility of
caring for his unwell younger sister
Ariana in a conversation filled with
regret Dumbledore shared with Harry that
he greatly resented his responsibility
as Ariana's Guardian feeling as though
his talents were being wasted with such
a task
this was also around the time that he
met Gaelic Grindelwald who inflamed his
hunger for greatness and power even more
the two formed a close relationship
bonding of the idea of uniting the Fable
Deathly Hallows and using them to take
over the Wizarding World and subjugate
muggle kind yes the widely celebrated
and famously just Albus Dumbledore once
wished to force humans into subservience
this of course also demonstrates
Dumbledore's openness to Prejudice in
his youth which as we discussed earlier
is another one of the values frequently
associated with slytherins
fortunately Dumbledore eventually moved
away from this type of thinking no
longer hiding hateful and harmful
ideologies behind obscure Concepts such
as the greater good in fact Albus even
went so far as to carefully remove
himself from positions of great power in
order to help keep his propensity for
ambition at Bay for example in 1932 he
turned down the opportunity to be the
supreme magwump leader of the
international Confederation of wizards
he also turned down on several occasions
the opportunity to become Minister for
magic while catching up with Harry and
limbo in 1998 he explained that he
turned the position down repeatedly for
one main reason he didn't trust himself
with that much power I meanwhile was
offered the post administer for magic
not once but several times naturally I
refused I had learned that I was not to
be trusted with power but you'd have
been better much better than funj or
scrimja burst out Harry would I our
stumbledore have heavily I'm not so sure
I had proven as a very young man that
pow was my weakness and my Temptation it
is a Curious Thing Harry but perhaps
those who are best suited to power are
those who have never sought it those who
like you have leadership thrust upon
them and take up the mantle because they
must and find their own surprise that
they wear it well I was safer at
Hogwarts and it's for this reason that
Dumbledore remained had mastered
Hogwarts for as long as he did he simply
didn't want to have access to any more
power this suggests that despite getting
far better at suppressing his Ambitions
Dumbledore continued to fear what he may
do if given the opportunity for power
Dumbledore was also very resourceful
despite keeping himself confined to the
position of Hogwarts at Master Albus
still managed to use who and what he had
access to in order to accomplish the
many plans he put into action over the
years he was a meticulous planner which
was evident by the end of the Harry
Potter series when his six year long
mentorship of Harry was revealed to have
been motivated by Dumbledore's desire to
set the boy who lived up to sacrifice
himself and defeat Lord Voldemort Albus
also uses his own impending death after
touching the cursed heirloom ring of
Marvel agaunt to his Advantage arranging
for Professor Snape to kill him thereby
saving Draco Malfoy from having to
commit murder against his will and
solidifying Snape's position with the
dark lord as a loyal Death Eater which
of course he was not in Harry's sixth
year Dumbledore also used him as bait to
convince horoslaghorn to return to
Hogwarts as the potions Professor so
that he could eventually use Harry to
get Slughorn to share what he told Tom
Riddle about horcruxes and so time and
time again Dumbledore used the people
and things at his disposal to help him
achieve his goals called calculating and
resourceful which leads us to the fact
that the Dumbledore was also an
incredibly cunning wizard while some may
argue that Professor Dumbledore was
smart to line him more with other
ravenclaws the way in which he utilized
his Brilliance was a master class in
being cunning throughout the series
there are many examples of Dumbledore
leveraging his skill but one of the most
notable ways in which Albus showcases
his cunning is through his Flawless
manipulations of those around him of
course we primarily see this with Harry
with his ultimate manipulation being
that he trained up the boy to be how did
Professor Snape put it oh yes a pig for
Slaughter but we also see this with
others for example Dumbledore
manipulates news Commander into being an
unlikely hero during the uprising of
Gaelic Grindelwald and on a much smaller
scale we also see Dumbledore's
calculated manipulation in place during
Harry's second year when he hired
gilderoy Lockhart to be the newest
professor of defense against her dark
arts knowing that Lockhart was a fraud
and believing that this position would
reveal him as search to The Wizarding
World of course he could have just
called him out but that would have
lacked Dumbledore's affinity for
cleverness and intricate planning while
of course it goes without saying that
almost every character in Harry Potter
could be sorted into any number of
houses there does seem to be some
particularly strong evidence suggesting
that Dumbledore may have been a better
fit for Slytherin rather than Gryffindor
whether it was simply a plot decision
made early on in the series which then
couldn't be altered or the character of
Dumbledore asking the Sorting Hat to
place him in Gryffindor of the Slytherin
as Harry did remains to be seen all I
know is that Alba's Dumbledore would
have made a great balanced Edition do
this otherwise rather narrowly defined
House of Slytherin but I also can't make
a statement like that without next
exploring why what if damodu was in
southern now let me just kick this off
by saying the Dumbledore being sorted
into Slytherin instead of Gryffindor
could potentially serve as the Catalyst
for an unfathomable number of changes in
Wizarding World law for those unfamiliar
there is a concept from Chaos Theory
called the butterfly effect that
illustrates how a small change in one
part of a system can lead to significant
and unpredictable outcomes in another
part of the system over time the name
Butterfly Effect comes from the idea the
flapping of a butterfly's Wings in one
location could potentially set off a
chain of events that eventually lead to
something like the formation of a
tornado in another location in essence
it symbolizes the idea that seemingly
insignificant actions can have
far-reaching and Amplified consequences
it's used to illustrate the idea that
even the smallest changes can lead to
outcomes that appear and related or
disproportionate so as you can imagine
if such small things have this sort of
power a range is big as Dumbledore being
sorted into Slytherin could
theoretically result in an entirely
different Wizarding World altogether
but here's where it gets really
interesting I don't actually think much
would have changed I think Dumbledore
would have very much remained Dumbledore
you see despite being sorted into
Gryffindor Dumbledore was still quite
Machiavellian often pulling the puppet
strings on others and allowing events to
unfold in a way that peaceful fit he'd
like to control the narrative but not
for his own personal satisfaction he
exhibited many stereotypically Slytherin
traits while remaining in Gryffindor
which tells me that Dumbledore was not
overly influenced by his affiliation
with one of the four Hogwarts houses
Dumbledore was also able to on multiple
occasions recognize and subdue his
desire for power something which I feel
sets him apart from some of the other
slytherins in the story I think that his
association with Grindelwald and his
youth is a pretty good indication of
what he might have been like in
Slytherin very tempted But ultimately
able to avoid straying down the path of
Darkness Dumbledore was not a man who
believed the past had any power over
dictating the future he was also quite
outspoken about the fact that the lines
are exceptionally blurred when it comes
to the traditional Good vs Evil
dichotomy there are quite a few
Dumbledore quotes in line with this
messaging here are a few of them it
matters not what someone is born but
what they grow to be this quote means
that a person's true worth is not
determined by where they come from or
who their family is but rather what kind
of person they've become based on their
growth and development here Dumbledore
reminds us that just because someone
comes from humble beginnings or faces
obstacles in life does not mean they
cannot achieve great things through
their own efforts and determination
while we may come from different places
and speak in different tongues our
hearts beat as one this quote emphasizes
that while people may be from different
backgrounds and have different cultures
they can still have a common Bond
through their shared Humanity Dumbledore
is pointing out that despite our
differences in language geography
nationality or blood status we share the
same basic emotions and experiences and
that should bring us together rather
than separate us differences of habit
and language are nothing at all if our
aims are identical and our hearts are
open this quote suggests that despite
our differences we can still work
towards the same goals as long as we
share the same passion and kindness
Dumbledore is saying that superficial
differences are insignificant in the
face of a shared aim or desire and that
an open heart can help bridge any gaps
and bring people closer together but if
you still aren't convinced here are some
more of the reasons for why I believe a
Slytherin Dumbledore is effectively the
same as a Gryffindor Dumbledore core
values Dumbledore's core values of love
compassion and the pursuit of good were
deeply ingrained within him independent
of his house affiliation throughout his
life Dumbledore consistently displayed
these values which played a critical
role in shaping The Wizarding world's
future I think that regardless of his
house Dumbledore's personal agency would
have driven him to make similar choices
and take similar actions for example
Dumbledore's decision to form the Order
of the Phoenix and fight against
Voldemort was driven by his commitment
to protecting the innocent preserving
freedom and upholding Justice these
values remained unchanged and were not
necessarily influenced by his house
affiliation house stereotypes and
individuality while house affiliations
in Hogwarts carry certain stereotypes
it's important to remember that these
stereotypes do not Define an
individual's entire character each
student possesses a unique combination
of attributes that cannot be solely
attributed to their house Dumbledore
even in southern would have retained his
own complexity and individuality
Dumbledore had a very strong character
and I'm not sure that would have changed
in any scenario influence of
Dumbledore's mentorship but now you
might be wondering wouldn't this have
changed his Dynamic with Harry well I
don't think the Dumbledore's house had
anything to do with it in Truth the
impact of Dumbledore's guidance and
mentorship always extended Beyond his
own house as the Headmaster Dumbledore
had the opportunity to shape the minds
and values of students from all four
houses his mentorship empowered Harry to
challenge evil Foster into house unity
and be a driving force in the war
against Voldemort while Dumbledore being
sorted into Slytherin would have added
an interesting layer to his character
and potentially provided some unique
perspectives I just don't think things
would have been as different as you
might expect although I could be very
wrong on this and that's why I want to
hear from you guys do you agree how do
you think a southern Dumbledore would
have impacted the Wizarding World leave
a comment down below and as always if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
like it and subscribe to the channel
also be sure to check out the content on
Spotify as well as extra content on my
second Channel Harry Potter Theory extra
until next time remember the world isn't
split into good people and Death Eaters
we've all got both light and dark inside
us what matters is the part we choose to
act on foreign